repeat offenders leaving a trail of
Carnage in Liberal cities a career a
career criminal with 17 prior arrests
randomly stabbing two teenage girls who
were visiting New York City on Christmas
Day The Lunatic reportedly yelled I want
all the white people dead thankfully
both the girls sustained
non-life-threatening injuries cops
arresting 36-year-old homeless man
Steven Hutcherson for the ruthless
attack he's facing multiple hate crime
charges including attempted murder just
two weeks ago huton pleaded guilty to
third degree assault after he reportedly
threatened to kill a man but the judge
let him out the victim in that previous
attack telling the New York Post that
Hutcherson shouldn't have been on the
streets at all and New York city mayor
Eric Adams well he's weighing in on what
happened anytime you have incidents in
these high-profile locations it sends
the feeling of you know people don't
feel safe and that's why we have to make
sure we you know zero in make the arrest
as soon as possible
uh and make sure we get those repeated
offenders off our streets uh Kandy maybe
people don't feel safe because somebody
with 17 prior including pulling a gun on
a man was walking around on the streets
it's Grand Central Grand Central is one
of the places where when you're visiting
the city and you want to go somewhere
iconic and christmy that's where you go
nice family from South America sitting
down trying to have breakfast and this
guy comes up stabs one girl in the back
the other in the thigh they're very
lucky that they weren't murdered cuz
that's what he was trying to do but he's
had this intent you know the prior with
the gun and and the man he was telling I
don't care if they gave you a green card
go back to where you're from and you
know he's racist he's violent I don't
know what these judges are waiting for
to happen next but that's what is making
the city feel unsafe is because it is
unsafe because they're doing a really
really bad job of keeping violent people
who've already committed violent
felonies off the street because guess
what they're going to do and it doesn't
matter if it's organ ganized retail
theft or assault they're going to do it
again they feel him Bolden I get it he's
mentally ill but the judge releases him
over and over and over again but to no
psychiatric care it's it's it is
mindboggling and it's not just about
feeling unsafe the mayor is also not
doing enough to work with the da to make
sure these people are kept off the
streets Jessica that that's kind of the
premise here this guy is insane I guess
but he's also racist and trying to kill
people he's violent and so with 17 prior
fences the the most recent one being
pulling a gun out or allegedly holding
it to a guy that wasn't white and saying
why are you working for white people and
then threatening to kill him for going
to work he gets arrested and now you
have a justice system that says maybe
it's because he has mental problems that
they don't want to put him in jail what
I know that there's a a lot of talk in
this city about people about the places
where mentally uh mentally ill people
used to go that are shut down and
there's reasons for that so then what's
the answer to
it make more of them that run properly
and treat people who are mentally ill
with dignity and they can get the care
that they need make sure that our
shelter system isn't overcrowded with
people who shouldn't be in it and this
is I'm I have very little bad to say
about undocumented people who are here
in the country but they have taken
shelter beds away from New Yorkers and
people from Chicago and Baltimore and
all these places who have a right to be
part of the system here and that's a big
problem so there was abuse should be
creating more I'm not for the island and
wherever like sending them away to some
sort of colony but obviously this needs
to be addressed and I think that mayor
Adams is doing the right thing in
talking about feelings because crime and
safety is one of those issues that is a
feeling issue the statistics and we went
over this last week the FBI New FBI
stats do not hold up that things are
worse than they were we've gotten so
much better over year overy year from
2022 to 2023 violent crime property
crime murder has plummeted at the
fastest rate ever recorded those are the
fact no but there was obviously a huge
Spike at the beginning of the pandemic
and it has come down substantially it is
safer today for us to walk outside than
it was at this time last year period end
of story but you can't change how people
feel about it if they see that their
products are locked up at a CVS if this
is happening in Grand Central where you
feel safe or you should feel safe Pen
Station never felt as safe as Grand
Central to me um but that is the problem
but we need we need proper Humane care
but for these sick people on the
statistics issue when it comes to cities
like New York a lot of crimes aren't
actually properly recorded so therefore
the crime stats are going down even
though when mayor Adam says well people
don't feel safe no it's not they don't
feel safe there's a big difference
between feeling away and then reality of
not being safe if you can't sit down at
Grand Central one of the most famous
tourist destinations in the entire world
on Christmas morning with your family
without having your lung collapsed by a
17 time offender you are unsafe and that
is happening all over the place with the
people randomly stabbing girls Thea
owners and it's so interesting that in
this city they're really tough on
someone who is wanting to follow the
rules wants to get handgun to defend
themselves if they break any of the laws
they're going straight to jail but this
guy pulls out a gun and threatens
someone with a deadly weapon and he gets
out back on the street so he can
victimize these young girls from another
country again and that's the whole point
if you let these people out of jail
under the guise of mental illness which
is not an excuse by the way especially
if they're violent they're going to hurt
someone else you are putting innocent
people in positions where their lives we
change forever as a result of those
decisions it doesn't
the shopkeeper with video surveillance
footage showing that he was defending
himself with a knife he goes to jail no
questions asked you have to Rally to get
him out of jail uh for defending himself
with a knife this guy's got 17 PRI Tyrus
he uses a knife and you know let's hope
he stays in jail this time here's what's
disheartening the police department the
defunded police department did their job
17 times yeah they've arrested this guy
yeah men and women in blue are doing
their part then he goes to a DA and he
right back out this guy's claiming he
wants to kill white people because he's
figured out that is a defense now he's
oppressed even though he's stabbing
people from South America and a man of
color doesn't matter it was the he
they're doing the Hamas thing where we
attack pillage do what we want to and if
you say anything to us uh it was because
the other group started first a million
years ago so he's doing these things he
says I want to kill all white people
it's a defense now it's a def he feels
oppressed he feels something wrong wrong
the the way that they're tweaking the
system in these cities everyone should
be afraid 17 times this man was put in
cuffs book him Johnson and he was turned
out in the street so if you have
daughters and it doesn't matter what
color you are if you're a minority and
you're out there going well he wants to
kill white people this dude is killing
any or stabbing or attempting to kill
two girls from South America he doesn't
really care he just knows what to say so
whenever you hear the mental illness
thing he's not he's smart enough to know
what to yell because that's the that
will get him attention from these groups
who were saying he's oppressed yeah I
think Katie brings up probably the best
point about this is that statistics are
not layered year after year the same
when you don't have as many cops writing
as many police reports and a lot of
crimes are looked at as we know this
person isn't going to be held
accountable and so I think that's part
of the problem 17 times they did the job
all right from Banning gas stoves to
cracking down on washing machines
Democrats are declaring war on your
appliances but maybe not theirs have
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now